então boa noite
há muitos anos atrás quando eu tinha 15
anos
no primeiro dia da aula o professor de
filosofia entrou na sala e fez uma
pergunta o que é filosofia e nós pegamos
nas canetas fica no norte
apolino filosofia é fiel e claro
estávamos todos errados manda aqui o
sentimento deu nos uma definição e diz
que é uma reflexão sobre questões
importantes tais como qual é o sentido
da vida
ops tenho um raio em cima neste momento
porque eu percebi que na realidade essa
é a pergunta que eu tenho sempre tido
dentro de mim e nem fazia ideia que
tinha mas a partir daí que o momento
tornou a coisa mais importante
durante aquela altura pareceu muito
tempo e não foi assim tanto mas foram
pelo menos alguns anos durante alguns
anos foi um questionamento
[Música]
eu procurei nos filósofos eu procurei
procurei nas regiões procurando essa
cirurgia procurou ia procurar enfim em
todo lado
peter wittig a visão bem por uma
resposta que um se desfizesse e não
encontrei
não encontrei nada que eu dissesse ó sim
isto é o sentido da vida pra mim
então um dia pode imaginar
na altura e os meus amigos e colegas não
é a minha angústia existencial não é
as raparigas criam namorados os rapazes
criam mota e para além disso é que o
king custeava mim não dizia muito todos
aqueles que estavam à minha volta então
eu sentia um pouco diferente será talvez
a tempo com um marginal no sentido e um
dia talvez um dia em que não tinha
sentido - - amava o fim dos associados
ao menos compreendida digamos formamos
uma idéia na minha cabeça a idéia de que
muito do sofrimento muito do meu
sofrimento e muito sofrimento que eu vi
a minha volta
tem a ver com falta de respeito falta de
compreensão e falta de aceitação
tentação de tudo o que é um pouco
diferente de todas aquelas que não são
como padrão e por conseguinte e que nós
julgamos do exterior sem nunca nos
colocarmos no lugar dela eu sentia que
as pessoas não se conseguiu colocar no
meu lugar e por conseguinte o julgavam
de uma forma exterior sem ter em
consideração as condições com as
circunstâncias
o que eu sentia e por conseguinte por 5
provavelmente fazia a mesma coisa com os
outros e naquela entusiasmo
desenvolvimento desse uma idéia no meu
espírito e isso é uma coisa que eu nunca
quero fazer eu nunca mais quero fazer
isto e então pensei uma vez que nós
somos em parte mas bastante numa
proporção bastante grandes o fruto das
nossas condições são frutos da nossa
educação são fruto da nossa cultura etc
então se o multiplicar as minhas
experiências se eu fizer tudo aquilo que
a vida me apresentar em mesmo aquilo que
não me apresentar
eu fui à procura quanto mais
experiências ao acumular mais um com se
for no lugar das outras pessoas e - e
hoje vou julgar
e esta ideia que terminou no meu
espírito ambiente tornou o suficiente da
minha vida eu sabia que ainda não era
aquilo que estava à procura mas foi tipo
um sentido de vida provisório por
enquanto e servo e lança ilo
infelizmente pra mim ter investigado
física e provavelmente saúde mental não
tem muito tempo florista e apreensão
porque muito rapidamente ao quintal
disse ao sair de portugal
e aí viver para a bélgica encontrei o
dízimo
estamos a falar das décadas de 70 do
início da década de 70 já sou velhinha
ii
nessa altura os primeiros mestres
budistas tibetanos estava a começar a
chegar sabe buscar começaram a chegar à
índia o nepal o butão e por extensão a
estava a começar a chegar também à
europa onde era mais fácil entrar em
contato com ele o uso das suas aqui
trouxe propósito algumas fotos de quatro
deus um dos quais vocês conhecem de
certeza mas acho que provavelmente não
são métodos que já faleceram estes
chamadas do jovem repórter
este era o 17º e tem uma linhagem como o
dalai lama é o 14º e está no 17º andar
mapa
este chamava de 1.500 empate também já
faleceu e este é mais conhecido não
precisa de apresentações
sua santidade o dalai lama o que
aconteceu foi que quando eu comecei é
poder e tivemos muita sorte é que os que
como eu se tomarão budistas nessa época
tivemos acesso é este semestre que não
tiveram quase inacessíveis
é porque era uma tal do tal nível que
era muito difícil chegar junto ao
chegarem aqui o acidente
como não tinha os milhares de seguidores
que tinham no oriente foi possível da
próxima los bastante perto e apesar da
distância lingüístico é porque eu não
falo tentando e eu não falava inglês
apesar da distância lingüística e
cultural e do grande fosso cultural que
existe entre nós era fácil muito fácil
sentir todo toda compaixão toda a
sabedoria toda a empatia toda a
sociedade que os irmana vão e também
tudo respeito respeito profundo por não
só por todos os outros seres humanos mas
inclusivamente por todas as formas de
vida é uma coisa muito típica do budismo
o respeito de todas as formas de vida do
meio ambiente do planeta é de 7 e também
entende que o que tinha pra mim o meu
meu objetivo de vida temporário não é de
conseguir lidar sentir empatia com as
pessoas sem a julgar por fora como a
misteriosa nem própria está em entender
as suas condições e as suas
circunstâncias
percebi que eu tinha uma grande
capacidade para fazer isso
quem batia era a grande especialidade
deus e então foi que eu lembro eu quis
eu olhava para 11 e quando for grande
quer sido assim
i e um dia resolvi colocar uma questão
mais concreta resolve colocar uma
questão mas como é que pode
como é que eu posso tomar uma pessoa
assim como é que eu como é que nós
podemos desenvolver essa que é possível
dentro tinha o que nos impede qual é
obstáculo e foi ter com um dos meus
mestres e fiz a pergunta diretamente e
eu disse
o grande problema é se traçar uma linha
e depuseram de um lado e puser todos os
outros do outro lado e esse era que o
teu bem estar às suas opiniões e suas
idéias e que o que tu quer é mais
importante do que o restar as opiniões e
que o que as pessoas outras pessoas
querem vocês vão estar tudo vai estar em
algum conflito automático com toda a
gente pensava em quem é que vai achar
que eu vou estar é mais importante que o
deu esse consórcio da minha mãe mas
mesmo assim não saí do é então
compreendi que se nós virmos o mundo
desta forma o conflito é inevitável
porque nesta imagem
és tu que estás aqui do lado está o uso
do outro mesmo lugar ou em qualquer uma
das outras pessoas ela vai ver isso da
mesma maneira e por conseguinte todo
todos os conflitos
todas as incompreensões inclusivamente
todos os devora se fosse o resultado
disto é claro aviso os primeiros outra
coisa
transformando em horizontal muito mais
então mesmo nível
o teu bem estar é tão importante pra ti
como vai estar o joão é importante pra
eu como vai estar da maioria é
importante para ela isto no processo
toda a gente no mesmo plano sido
considerados que o teu tal como garantiu
também estar as suas opiniões exclusiva
e som essenciais são muito importantes
para todas as outras são igualmente
importantes importante disso tudo
respeitar isso provavelmente jamais
encontrar mais gente de acordo contigo
para não dizer toda a gente
se eu achar que o meu bem estar dos meus
empresa são respeitados ao mesmo nível
que vão estar os interesses da outra
pessoa já é aceitável não é
além do que quando eu vejo isto assim eu
acho que o meu bem-estar entra em
conflito com os outros e entra
porque eu acho que é mais importante mas
se ouvir isto assim nosso estado não
está em conflito
somos todos seres humanos e 90 por cento
das nossas necessidades são comuns
temos 99 ou não não 9% da lei e nem
comum e os nossos interesses convergem
então se nós virmos um mundo assim é
muito provável que tenhamos muito mais
em comum que tenhamos interesses e e que
tenhamos e que o nosso bem-estar possa
ser obtido de uma forma comum e não de
uma forma consensual e não de uma forma
conflito asa maravilhoso
pensei eu tudo bem mas como é que eu
faço agora para transformar isto que é
muito bonita de se dizer mas isto numa
atitude concreta do dia a dia como é que
eu faço por e quistos eja minha se
transformam na minha maneira de ser
eu só tinha o estudo por receptor fim da
guiné 2.500 anos dá tempo para
desenvolver truck
então eu disse quando estava em casa
fazendo digitação ou se estiveram no
sítio qualquer com outras pessoas eu não
desisti porque não era assim muita
realidade não mas agora eu posso estar
populares estiveram no transporte
público se eu estiver numa sala de
espera onde quer que eu esteja que tem
alguém na minha frente ao mesmo que eu
imagino alguém na minha frente eu olho
pra pessoa pensa assim
tal como eu essa pessoa não quer sofrer
espero que ninguém espera um caminho até
isto usuário dentro de mim e eu dizer é
claro que tal é óbvio tal como eu essa
pessoa quer ser feliz e espero ter um
bocadinho da esposa e minha tese é claro
que não
sim
depois penso que se quiser que mais
difícil
tal como eu essa pessoa faz coisas boas
mas tal como eu também cometer é certo é
que tal como eu
esta pessoa merece todo respeito porque
se eu estivesse na situação dela
quem salva estaria a fazer o mesmo
portanto eu descobri que este exercício
que é infantil
mas se repetirmos muitas muitas muitas
vezes modifica por completo a nossa
visão do mundo e permita uma base sólida
estável e razoável para o respeito por
toda a gente
agora é só experimentar é obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]